E
ALSO HEARING STORY OF HEROISM
AND EL DORADO, AN OFF-DUTY
BORDER PATROL AGENT WHO WAS
GETTING A HAIRCUT WHEN HIS WIFE,
TEACHER, TESTED HIM "THERE'S AN
ACTIVE SHOOTER, HELP, I LOVE
YOU."
HE GOT UP, GRABBED THE BARBER'S
SHOTGUN, AND HEADED FOR THE
SCHOOL.
HE ENTERED THE BUILDING, BEGAN
CLEARING ROOMS, AND EVACUATED
HIS OWN DAUGHTER AND OTHER
STUDENTS.
HERE NOW FOR A REACTION,
NATIONAL SECURITY EXPERT, AARON
COHEN ALONG WITH FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, TED WILLIAMS.
AARON, LET ME SAY.
ALL OF US KNOW EVEN IF WE ARE
NOT TRAINED, THE INSTINCT WE'VE
SEEN, INCLUDING THE MOTHER WHO
HOPPED THE FENCE AND RAN INTO
THAT BUILDING BEFORE IT WAS
CLEARED AND RESCUED HER OWN TWO
CHILDREN THAT THE TRAINING IS
THAT YOU GO IN AND YOU DON'T
STOP UNTIL YOU GET THAT SHOOTER.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON WHAT YOU
HEARD TODAY, WHICH CLEARLY IS
VERY CONCERNING TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
>> THERE HAS BEEN A VERY CLEAR
ACTIVE SHOOTER PROTOCOL IN PLACE
SINCE COLUMBINE, WHICH IS 30
PLUS YEARS AGO.
WHICH ESSENTIALLY LET THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY TO
DEVELOP A PRETTY BASIC, BUT
FUNCTIONAL ACTIVE SHOOTER
RESPONSE WHICH BASICALLY STATED
THAT WHOEVER SHOWS UP ON THE
SCENE, TAMMY, MAKES IT ENTRY
INTO THE SCHOOL.
THEY ARE TRAINED TYPICALLY TO
WHAT -- TO DO WHAT IS CALLED
FORMING UP INTO A DIAMOND
FORMATION.
THEY CAN GET MORE THAN TWO OR
THREE OFFICERS WITH THEM AT A
TIME.
AND THEN BEGIN TO HEAD TOWARD
THE DIRECTION OF THE FIRE.
THE SOLE PURPOSE IS TO
NEUTRALIZE THE THREAT.
YOU CAN'T -- YOU HAVE TO PUT
YOUR OXYGEN MASK ON FIRST.
CLEARLY THE PROTOCOL -- I WANT
TO BE CAREFUL NOT TO POOH-POOH
ALL THE LAW ENFORCEMENT ACROSS
THE COUNTRY BECAUSE THIS AGENCY
HAPPENS TO BE TAKEN HEAT RIGHT
NOW.
AND IT JUST SEEMS THAT FOR
WHATEVER REASON, THIS PARTICULAR
AGENCY DIDN'T HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE PROTOCOLS IN PLACE,
OR DIDN'T HAVE THE CONFIDENCE TO
BE ABLE TO PULL OFF MAKING ENTRY
WITH TWO OR THREE OFFICERS.
FOR WHATEVER REASON, THEY
BOTTLENECK IN THAT HIGHWAY AND
IT LEADS ME TO BELIEVE THAT THEY
DIDN'T HAVE THE STRESS TRAINING
TO BE ABLE TO ENGAGE THAT
SHOOTER AND UNDER DURESS -- WHAT
I MEAN BY THAT, THERE'S A
MASSIVE CHEMICAL DUNK THAT
HAPPENS.
>> I UNDERSTAND, BUT THAT'S THE
TRAINING.
TRAINING IS TO GET YOU USED TO
AN ENVIRONMENT SO WHETHER IT IS
ADRENALINE THAT GIVES YOU
AMNESIA OR ANY OTHER STRESS
HORMONES, DON'T DROP, BECAUSE
WHETHER YOU ARE TAKING A TEST OR
IF YOU ARE TRAINING FOR AN
ACTIVE SHOOTER, YOU DO IT
OVER -- YOU DO IT OVER, AND
OVER, AND OVER SO WHEN YOU ARE
REALLY DOING IT, IT IS NORMAL.
>> YOU ARE CAPABLE OF
FUNCTIONING UNDER THAT STRESS, I
AGREE WITH YOU 100%.
>> LET ME JUST SAY THAT WE ALL
HEAR IT -- WE DON'T NEED TO
REASSERT OUR SUPPORT EVEN THOUGH
WE DO EVERY DAY FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I AM KNOWN FOR THIS.
THOUGHT SUPPORTS, TED, WORKS
WHEN WE EAT -- BECAUSE HAVE
STANDARDS.
AND AS A RESULT SUPPORT
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
MILITARY.
I DON'T STILL ALSO HAS TO BE
THAT WHEN THE STANDARDS ARE
BREACHED WE ARE FREE TO KNOW
WHEN THERE'S A PROBLEM.
TED, I THINK THIS IS WHAT WE ARE
DEALING WITH.
>> YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IT MUST BE ADDRESSED.
HE IS NOT TOLD US WHO MISLED
HIM.
NO HEADS HAVE ROLLED.
THE DEPARTMENT OF SAFETY, AN
OFFICER WHO CAME ON TODAY AND
SAID THAT IT WAS THE WRONG
DECISION.
WHAT WE NEED IS AN INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION.
19 ANGELS.
AND YOU HAD TWO TEACHERS TO DIE
AS A RESULT AND POLICE OFFICERS,
19 OF THEM.
TWIDDLING THEIR FINGERS.
YOU HAD A BRAVE YOUNG GIRL WHO
WAS ON THE TELEPHONE, ON THE 911
CALL, AND SHE WAS TRYING TO GET
SOME HELP.
SHE WAS SAYING, I NEED HELP.
THERE ARE KIDS IN HERE.
PLEASE SEND SOMEBODY, PLEASE
SEND SOMEBODY.
THAT MUST BE INVESTIGATED,
TAMMY.
>> EVEN TODAY AT THE PRESS
CONFERENCE, THERE WAS AN FBI
REPRESENTATIVE THERE, A FIELD
AGENT, WHO SAID IF WE FIND THAT
THERE IS A FEDERAL -- WE WILL
INVESTIGATE.
CLEARLY EITHER IT IS THE STATE
OR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, WHICH
CERTAINLY THEY DON'T HAVE A
HISTORY AT THIS POINT OF
BEING -- ANYTHING WE CAN TRUST
EITHER.
BUT MY GOODNESS, SOMETHING DID
HAPPEN WITH EITHER LEADERSHIP OR
SOMEONE ELSE WHEN YOU HAVE THIS
MAGICAL DECISION THAT NO MORE
CHILDREN ARE AT RISK, IT IS NOW
A DIFFERENT THING.
THAT SEEMS INEXPLICABLE.
IS THERE ANY WAY TO EXPLAIN
THIS?
>> IT IS INEXPLICABLE, BUT THE
REALLY IMPORTANT PIECE OF MEAT
TO HANG ON HEAR, HEAR IS THE
LACK OF FUNDAMENTAL RESPONSE.
THE RESPONDER HAS ONE GOAL.
WE HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH THIS
IN ISRAEL FOR YEARS.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHETHER IT'S A
TERRORIST OR AN ACTIVE SHOOTER.
THE MOTIVE DOESN'T MATTER.
THE ACTION GETS ADDRESSED THE
SAME WAY.
WHICH IS TO SPOT THE THREATS,
NEUTRALIZE THE THREAT AND LOOK
FOR MORE THREATS UNTIL THAT
ENTIRE SCHOOL HAS BEEN SWEPT.
AND EVEN THERE, THE PROPERTY
DOESN'T GET STERILIZED UNTIL THE
SPECIAL ENTRY TEAM GETS IN AND
METHODICALLY OPENS UP EVERY
CLOSET.
THIS AGENCY KNOWS THERE WAS A
MAJOR COLOSSAL FAILURE.
I THINK TO ADD TO YOUR OTHER
GUSTS POINT HERE, I DO THINK
THERE NEEDS TO BE INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION.
I ALSO THINK THAT THE LEADERSHIP
OF THIS POLICE AGENCY SHOULD
TAKE THE RESPONSIBILITY TO STEP
OUT.
THAT WOULD BE THE RIGHT THING TO
DO AT THIS POINT.
LET'S GET SOME FRESH BLOOD IN
THERE.
THIS IS A TACTICAL SITUATION
HERE.
WHICH LISTEN, FOR EVERY SECOND
WASTED, ANOTHER INNOCENT PERSON
IS KILLED.
THAT IS HOW LONG IT TAKES TO
PULL THE TRIGGER.
THESE OFFICERS NEED TO BE
FLYING.
THAT'S AT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I THINK THIS NATION COULD
ALSO LEARN A GREAT DEAL FROM
ISRAELI POLICE, THE ISRAELI
APPROACH IN DEALING WITH
DYNAMICS.
I THINK IT COULD BE